a scalp the filler and then Aviva Lord
God
it's the perfect rivalry the baseline
player and the net Russia in a turret
offset
this book how does it feel knowing you
can make history of you when you're
fixable
[Music]
no special things says funny trollop
the only thing standing between Borg and
that record is you you and Borg are as
different as two people could possibly
be respected Aegis communications Mexico
the bigger talents the Train blorgon
like being hit by a sledgehammer
[Music]
in fact how do you spot to Makkah most
comments before the tournament
the machine will soon break down I'm
just like anybody else not a machine
getting exact how much the vault breaker
through any Krypton gun to crown are
done until it's anonymous player
why did your thump answer the question
you don't understand what the [ __ ] it
takes to play tennis shut up
but people like all care like it
everything to sting
everything everything me gets left out
on that [ __ ] corner another you
understand cuz now you do it
[Applause]
you
[Applause]
tell their company
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you